like it just sounds like there's
something missing from the story I I
don't know I don't know yeah this is
where men have to come in yeah I'm
listening doesn't man feel like women
money is important in a relationship 110
but okay gone if you were now with a
woman but you're not financially happy
where you are
would you break off the relationship no
no you're not a question okay if it's
stressing if it's stressing you out and
you're feeling like I can only focus on
money I can only feel stressed if you're
the reason I'm stressed because
if money's I agree with you in the sense
that men do have a lot of pressures but
I believe that's just the way it is and
and men have to deal with that pressure
becomes is part of being the man okay
but if I'm married to you and this is
why I think everybody's gonna start
thinking there's a piece missing because
even as a man and this is me speaking as
a man if I'm married to you the only
reason not to feel the type of way is if
I made to feel that way so it's either
he feels that way because of someone the